c'est puissant proche du pouvoir un
homme discret qui choisit de sortir de
l'ombre
l'ex patron de la firme de consultant
makinzee comparé en comité parlementaire
l'entreprise qui se dirigeait jusqu'en
2018 a reçu près de 117 millions de
dollars en contrat du gouvernement
fédéral depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
libéraux il défend son intégrité je ne
suis pas un partenaire interrogé à
répétition sur ses liens avec le Premier
ministre
toute amitié avec Justin Trudeau et
Martel qu'il n'a rien à voir avec les
contrats accordés à mackenza même si
c'était lui le grand patron pendant
plusieurs années
en 2017 Justin Trudeau vantait le carnet
d'adresses de Dominique Barton
c'est pour ça que nous l'avons recruté
disait-il Dominique Barton a été chois
par Ottawa en 2016 pour présider le
Conseil consultatif en matière de
croissance économique plus tard il a été
nommé ambassadeur canadien en Chine
Dominique Barthon Martel qu'il s'est
investi pour servir son pays et pas ses
intérêts personnels afin de firstra
training il se dit frustré par les
insinuations en ce sens ces dernières
heures l'opposition aussi fait monter la
pression concernant le recours
grandissant au firmes de consultants par
le gouvernement fédéral est-ce qu'on a
mis le ministère l’immigration sous une
relative tutelle entre les mains de
Mackenzie puis est-ce qu'on est en train
de privatiser une partie du cabinet du
Premier ministre Dominique barthin
défend le recours aux entreprises comme
makinze en qualifiant les pratiques de
la fonction publique de désuète
nous sommes à l'âge de pierre dit-il
l'opposition réclame une liste des
clients de makinze à la recherche de
conflits d'intérêts par exemple la firme
a été embauchée par la défense nationale
pour l'appuyer dans sa modernisation or
mais kinzee a aussi conseillé des
entreprises américaines qui équipent le
monde militaire comment ça fonctionne
lorsque l'entreprise Mackenzie donne des
conseils au ministère de la défense du
Canada et à la fois à la compagnie
lorsqu'il Morton vous voyez pas qu'un
problème de conflit d'intérêt flagrants
entre les différentes clients sont
étanches le recours aux firme de
consultants doit mener à une réflexion
en profondeur de la part des
parlementaires selon cette expert en
éthique se concentrer sur la dépendance
des administrations publiques sur un
oligopole de 4,5 firmes multinationales
qui détiennent des informations
stratégiques qui sont d'intérêt public
mais qui dans les conditions actuelles
sont des propriétés privées en quelque
sorte ces dernières années mais Kenzie
n'est pas la seule firme qui a vu ses
contrats exploser avec le gouvernement
fédéral c'est aussi le cas de grandes
entreprises comme Deloitte ou Price
Waterhouse Cooper par exemple une
demande justement que le mandat du
Comité soit élargi pour étudier
l'empreinte de tous ces gros joueurs sur
l'appareil fédéral ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada Ottawa